hello I'm Becky buzzy Oh commercial
director for the cell biology business
at Thermo Fisher Scientific today we are
excited to bring together researchers
from around the world for our fifth
annual 24 hours of stem cells virtual
event during this year's event you'll
learn about new scientific advances
expand your research network and
discover the newest innovations to
advance your stem cell research new this
year is a special focus on young
investigators visit the Career
Development Center for access to career
development resources and tools at
Thermo Fisher Scientific we are
committed to enabling our customers to
make the world healthier cleaner and
safer I'm excited to welcome you all to
the fifth annual 24 hours of stem cells
thank you for joining us today and enjoy
the show
before you begin exploring first make
sure to review your personal profile
settings set your personal profile
settings using the profile settings menu
on the navigation bar your screen name
and other personal details are listed
here you can easily change what
information is made available to other
attendees in the virtual environment by
checking the small box to the right of
each detail when the green checkmark
shows that information is visible on
your public profile for all attendees
under the general settings tab here you
can also select your preferred event
timezone and language now that your
profile is set let's review what's
available in this year's event
if you're interested in the event
certification you can view the list of
required activities here to earn the
event certification you will need to
complete all activities on this list
activities must be completed in the
order they're shown track your progress
under the activities tab to see how
you're doing
once you have completed all six
activities you'll be able to download
your certificate of completion you will
receive an email shortly after with
instructions on requesting your t-shirt
new to this year's event is our Career
Development Center here you can access
free career advice along with other
educational opportunities such as
virtual training and handbooks the
presentations auditorium hosts both
on-demand and live presentations in the
exhibit hall
you can visit booths to learn about new
technologies products and resources
available to support your stem-cell
research
select a booth to view and learn about
new products and services offered by
thermo Fisher Scientific for that
research area browse the different
resources available by application you
can choose to view them now or save them
for later by adding them to your virtual
briefcase here you can also find a
schedule of the live chats that will be
hosted by thermo Fisher Scientific s--
R&D experts visit during your topic of
interest join the conversation and ask
our team your questions if you're local
to Japan or Korea please make sure to
check in with these regional booths here
you will find translated content and
live support staff available to answer
questions in your local language and if
you need any help just click on the
support tab here for virtual shows
support and email information from
modeling diseases to discovering
therapies and perhaps one day even
offering cures stem cells have the
potential to change the way we think
about medicine sharing new findings
research approaches and connecting with
other researchers is a great
for moving stem-cell research forward
thank you for attending today's virtual
event